i don't know what to do cause i've got
the grief but i'm still angry sister
wife star cody brown admits that his
split from ex-wife christine brown is
taking a toll on him so where are you
and cody at right now
cody and i are divorced we're completely
separate during sunday's one-on-one
reunion special the 52-year-old goes in
death with ho shukanya krishnan about
what he thinks went wrong in his
marriage to christine she told me once
she hated plural marriage first he
admits to overlooking christine's
growing dislike for polygamy over the
years
and then says he made a mistake by not
validating her concerns during the times
when she expressed them yeah that was
some arrogance there yeah some
some like my first reaction was like
i've been loving to you and i've been
this you know i've been this husband and
we've done this and we've done all this
together we've got these great memories
and we've got these beautiful children
and you hate polygamy what the crap
you know like honestly that was my
reaction instead of going oh i know it's
so hard and i'm looking back now
and i'm going if i could go back
would i save it all with just being
empathetic cody even reveals that due to
all the family drama with the other
wives and his divorce from christine
he's begun to question the lifestyle he
chose are you questioning your own
polygamy right now oh hell yes
yes i question it all the time
when you talk to women who were
struggling in it the pain in it speaking
of pain according to cody he was not
aware that christine was questioning
staying married to him mary i can't do
marriage with cody anymore i don't want
him you don't get to give up like that i
don't want to do it anymore
until he watched it play out on the show
i didn't know what was going on
i didn't know that she was going i don't
want to be married to cody anymore i
mean i'd heard rumors from my children
that she'd been kind of throwing things
around
uh and and i you know even other wives
saying oh she's always threatened that
she was gonna leave and i'm like
why am i in the dark here cody goes on
to describe their split as a single
moment that's been building up for years
this is just kind of the place that our
relationship is at the topic of his and
christine's lack of intimacy was also
laid out on the table the last few years
he just wasn't interested
he just wasn't and we basically just had
a non-intimate marriage completely and
we're like we wouldn't even touch we
wouldn't even hold hands but cody admits
that the reality of their divorce still
hurts my biggest problem
for all of this experience is that i'm
angry
well
fast forward to this moment and the
grief
that is settled in the heartbreak
and the awareness
but
it's not that simple
meanwhile new doors for christine have
opened since she announced her split
from cody in november of last year i'm
christine brown you know me from sister
wives but what you might not know is how
much i love to cook the sister wife star
is getting her own digital cooking show
titled cooking with just christine on
tlc these look pretty great they smell
even better though according to the
announcement the 49 year old will be
bringing fans some of her favorite
recipes and as seen in the trailer there
will also be cameos from her and cody's
kids more than anything i think that
what we do
impacts our kids whether we wanted to or
not honestly out of cody's 18 children
christine is the mother of six she
entered the brown family's plural
marriage in 1994 as cody's third wife
we
don't have to do anything together but
as fans have seen on the show
christine's desire for independence has
caused major conflict between cody and
the other wives it's something et spoke
to the 49 year old about earlier last
year i really like living separate i
like my own space i like my own autonomy
i feel like i like me better now as and
i just feel like i've been able to
really
like raise my kids how i want to i
really have more of an independence and
i really i just
think the autonomy is really really nice
and i feel like as a person that i do
better with a little bit more distance